alopecia areata is an autoimmune form of
hair loss where T cells attack the
growing hair follicle it is not a
life-threatening form of autoimmunity
however it is a life altering form of
autoimmune disease
it affects patients in a very profound
and very personal way to undergo hair
loss I could say that with authority
because I'm one of them so the reason my
lab studies this is because I actually
have alopecia areata and that's what
really sparked us to do this type of
work over 6 million people in the u.s.
also suffer from various forms of
alopecia areata so this is a
tremendously large and motivated
population of patients who have no other
treatments available treatment for this
disease in the past has been hit miss
with steroids and with varying degrees
of success
we've been excited to see data both in
mice and now in people to show that we
can reverse this disease with small
molecules that are aimed at reversing
the inflammatory condition in humans the
trough reversal in the treatment of
alopecia areata got started based on the
clinical a genetic and immunologic
discoveries made by doctors Christiano
and Klein's
in investigating the genetics of
alopecia areata they were able to then
subsequently pinpoint to several immune
pathways that appear to be important in
alopecia areata the next step was
identifying available drugs that
actually inhibit these pathways and this
is the basis upon which ruxolitinib was
selected once the drug was selected we
then went about designing a trial to
preliminary test its effect on alopecia
areata we now have the ability to
identify potential targets for treatment
and using what some people call a
mechanism driven approach that is to
look for pathways that are altered in
human disease and then to see if those
alterations lend themselves to some type
of manipulation either pharmacologically
or Jen
to clay or both and I think that's what
we have in the case of this study which
is an autoimmune disease that has eluded
for decades any basic understanding of
the development and the causation of the
disease we went on to show which immune
pathways might be important in the cell
death of the hair follicle and then
using those insights we blocked those
pathways in the mouse models showed they
were efficacious and then went on to go
on to try medically relevant antibodies
and small molecules to see whether when
we block these pathways we could reverse
the alopecia areata and we showed that
it was true in mouse models and then
went on to go to a small series of
patients and show that the therapies
could also be effective in people we are
very committed to making sure that that
patients with alopecia areata have
access to this class of drugs hopefully
in a way sauna day that's not an
off-label indication meaning we'd like
to pursue getting a label getting an
indication for a jak inhibitor in
alopecia areata we're deeply committed
to doing that there are so many other
diseases if you will ahead of us other
diseases that might be considered much
more life-threatening or life-altering
than alopecia can sometimes get pushed
to the backburner or to the bottom of
the list but this has been the major
focus of our entire group and we would
like very much to make sure that this
ball gets across the finish line
whatever that takes and hopefully we'll
be joining with some pharmaceutical
partners to make sure that alopecia
stays top of mind and that someday this
is an approved indication for jak
inhibitor